[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour maman laudateurs la voit tout et
qu'on jette dans le frigo le hgd a déjà
prêté mama mama je te jure maman du
jamais vu une voiture congelés comme ça
au bled
après que
[Applaudissements]
je suis obligé tester obligé tapas choix
obligé
on
pourquoi les deux grands compositeurs
verdi et gounod ne s'entendait pas parce
que pendant que un othello l'autre l'avé
maria
[Rires]
et quand je sais il ya tellement de gens
qui vont pas ce qu'ils vont pas avoir
les références et qui vont régaler y
comprendre ce qu'ils ont compris vous
l'expliquer aux autres
au fait comment ça va avec ta copine
c'est plus ma copine oh merde bon du
coup je peux avouer que j'ai couché avec
elle tu m'en voudra pas c'est ma femme à
présent à
meilleure chose dans la rue les plus
simples
[Rires]
[Musique]
mimi tu m'appeler beau
féculent tu vaux comme un camion tu as
ami me dit notre gillot
jean à gino
et les gars ce soir vos restaurants oui
mais c'est vous qui payez vous piquer
c'est après